Speaker 1: One of the primary features and it
really is a feature for them. It's not a bug
of reactionary right wing culture
based politics is to create enemies
and then to argue that you are going to fight
against them and that they are dangerous and
that they are a threat to your way of life, and
that they are a threat to America and all of
these different things. And one such enemy for
the modern reactionary Republican is the vague
idea of communism, communists among our ranks.
They might be in the House of Representatives,
they might be in the Senate, they might be in
your schools teaching your kids things. And
I have just a delightful clip for you here.
Ron DeSantis, who is the governor of Florida,
he's in the middle of a reelection campaign.
He's up for reelection in November of 2022.
He did an event called Honoring Victims of
Communism. Now, I'm the first to tell you that
I am not a communist. I am against
any kind of authoritarianism, many of.
And when you say communist regimes, some
will say they weren't really communists.
Many so-called or believed communist regimes in
history have been authoritarian. And I'm against
authoritarianism no matter what it is wrapped in.
And I also recognize that this is a completely
bogus event at which Ron DeSantis is a virtue
signaling signaling for lack of a better term.
And this is just my favorite thing. He talks about
the Argentinean, Marxist revolutionary leader Che
Guevara, and he pronounces his name Cheikh Kway
Vara. He's furious with Cheikh, but he doesn't
even know his name. It's this is the epitome of
everything that is wrong with this right wing
reactionary movement. Let's take a look at it.
Speaker 3: You can see at a college campus,
students flying the hammer and sickle from the
old Soviet Union flag. You will see students
that will have t shirts with Che Guevara, Cheikh
K vara on the t shirts, you will see students
that will idolize people like Mao Zedong dung.
That to me bespeaks of a tremendous ignorance
about what those individuals represented.
Speaker 1: And the now
I am not fans of the I am not a fan of the
people that DeSantis is mentioning here.
But guys, an event honoring the victims of
communism, this is just another one of these
sort of red scare anti-communist type rants. Now,
the legacy of Alger as we knew him in Argentina.
It's it's not a legacy that is thrilling to
me, right? I mean, it's he was a revolutionary
guerrilla leader, wanted to overturn
capitalism everywhere by almost
whatever means might work. The whole the history
of it is that Guevara met the Castro brothers
and joined their movement in Cuba to overthrow
Batista and ushered in the decades and decades
and decades of authoritarian rule by the
Castros and ultimately ended up playing.
I'm trying to do this sort of like as fairly as
possible, controversial roles in various attempted
revolutions all over the world, including
unsuccessfully in Congo, Kinshasa, later in
Bolivia. Ultimately, Guevara was captured by CIA
assisted Bolivian forces and executed. And Guevara
is not a hero to me. But the virtue signaling
and reactionary fearmongering by DeSantis of,
you know, high schoolers and college kids who
like to wear the t shirt. This is not a major
political issue. Okay. Florida has some serious
problems. Housing affordability crisis in Florida,
median household income in Florida is 34th in
the country. Florida ranked third in opportunity
infrastructure in Florida, extraordinarily
problematic. Public education in Florida
really leaves something to be
desired. If you ranked states
by their equivalent HDI, what's called the
Human Development Index, Florida comes in
third, so it's not good. There's all sorts
of problems in Florida. And DeSantis is
talking about Cheikh Vara at a memorial honoring
the victims of communism. It's just absurd. And
I might. I can. Only imagine that if DeSantis does
end up running for president challenging. Maybe
it's going to be challenging TRUMP We don't
know what it's going to look like in 2024.
It's going to be more of the same reactionary
fear mongering that you can be absolutely sure of